[Music]
and nosy neighbors news submitted by
waffle fries oh I like waffle fries
better season me too do you guys
remember that YouTube video some waffle
fries no all right
sounds familiar was that it's
unforgivable the mayonnaise yeah yeah Oh
buddy Oh jeepers viral video they made
me a sandwich ditch like whatever it's
give me a chicken cell just waffle sauce
a man's home was raided after cops found
out he was using his garage as an
illegal strip club what's wrong with
that shouldn't be illegal look what an
entreprenuer it's just his wife slumming
around the song huh was funny you
mention his wife because he says that
the stripper pull up they found in his
home his wife and his daughter use it
for exercise Oh perfect it camila
calories which is very much cleaned it
how big is this garage did you guys know
that's triple popping some of them it's
not the girls spitting around some of
them oh really yeah all the poles what
are you saying what are you saying pull
itself spins and set up the girl oh
variants yes oh but some of them not all
of them and did you know that they wear
the plastic shoes so that it's for more
grip you know those like come fuck-me
pumps yeah I love those yeah but it's
also to help them for grip oh I didn't
know that I thought was just to entice
our penises that's all it makes my boner
go away when they go to the top and then
they [ __ ] plunge down and stop right
before their head stop oh [ __ ] man you
scared the [ __ ] out of me I thought
you're gonna book you're gonna [ __ ] your
brain literally scared the [ __ ] yeah I
love circus slaying everyone looks like
they're just about to die yeah ha ha
but then at the same time your conquers
you see titties you're like just focus
on the titties focus on the tip Wow [ __ ]
bout the dye we're in Amsterdam at the
sex show and the one part of the sex
show there's like this acrobatic lady
that comes out and it looks like a
really rickety like really dingy Theater
and the pole was attached to like a
ceiling like this so as soon as the
chick got on it you see the pole
kind of gone like this and then the two
people at the front like everyone in
there like know when there's they're
like in there's like a pervert or
anything it's just you just this is
tourism right so you're going so this is
normal people they see this thing like
shaking and instead of like being able
to enjoy the show everyone kind of like
yeah please don't fall please don't fall
they kind of strengthen the pole people
holding people in the audience because
all those one of those were like here's
the stage right the stage is in the
front and you know sometimes to get next
level the performers that go into the
audience yeah so it's one of those
things were like the girl comes out with
her angel wings she's I'm about to [ __ ]
everybody in this audience I was in the
bathroom it needs to meet so there's
this pole that starts coming out of the
ground and then of course it was mm-hmm
the audience but the minute she climbs
it this thing is like shaking out so and
now all all of the audience instead of
being in awe everyone's just like oh
[ __ ] were worried about this other young
girls safety yet and she also looked
like she was probably kidnapped and
brought their like and taken like all
the girls in this show look like that so
everyone's this that called [ __ ] let's
go scare what a fun story I know
stripper garage they all thing they were
captured like a Dakin you know i just
got wasn't really good shot i saw a girl
blow a cigarette smoke ira [ __ ] that's
pretty good pretty cigar on her [ __ ]
vagina inhale yes oh she must have
really good Kegel techniques yeah and
then she blew it up she blew it out did
it come out like this yeah diamond smoke
did she [ __ ] make a pirate ship out
of it
that's me really bad for your vagina I
know but not I like I just want to try
it you want to try you want to try
blowing cigarette smoke out of your
[ __ ] yeah I just know I want to know if
I can do it
what's wrong with that if you couldn't
do it
Texas that you did it okay not the video
no just say say that it's possible say
it is possible just so like intruders
why don't you do it without the
cigarette you know how I got the
supermarkets they put like the little
stream to see if the AC is working just
put the string just tape it to your clip
and see if you can make the stream
pushing out part worth it but the inhale
they're like oh you inhaled in the
stream ago no she wants to know how to
inhale oh I had a girlfriend who could
read through your nose really hard you
know I had a girlfriend who could
breathe in through it through that Wow
like she didn't go scuba diving and go
on the ocean and breathe through a
vagina yeah no I don't know she could
breathe or whatever she could suck it
what happens when a queef happened to go
through so I thought for sure it could
happen if I put my legs up that for sure
air is going in there you - yeah I mean
yeah then you get a doggystyle position
[Laughter]
you know what I do you know what I do it
I know that go okay that's good wait why
are you so much no no no there's so much
room for air that's the problem
[Laughter]
this fools like this man he's like let
me tell you something he's like what the
physics of it because it when I pound my
wife she can walk in a perfectly
straight line I that way cuz you know I
brought the noise why did you want to
take my dreams and just pluck it and rip
it apart I'm seeing what you say [ __ ]
up our sex life I hope you know that I
hope I'm so funny I can't wait I kind of
excited for like those kids out there
who haven't had sex yet and they hear
their first queef cuz you're gonna have
to sum up figure out how to [ __ ] this
girl while giggling I've done many
difficult things but it's hard to have
sex in giggle or when you're when you're
of a tender age calming them down after
they quit cuz you don't give a [ __ ] who
you just won enough no baby no it's
chill no I do like a car salesman thing
yeah yeah it's really hot Nikki lows
it's okay so what happened with this
whole thing okay so this guy is a 58
year old uh homeowner his name is David
oh so he the cops were a today because
they heard that he was having this
illegal strip club one of the wives
called probably the sixth place in North
Carolina and so he was silly he was
selling alcoholic beverages without it
obtaining a license she's like my
[ __ ] husband rampant AB in your
garage no that's what happened and he
was charging five dollars for the
entrance that's a very affordable deal
who was dancing his daughter and his
wife
yeah they don't mention who the
strippers were I bet you it was or was
ham the pokes you know they walk up all
sexy and [ __ ] he was doing all the job
he was the [ __ ] bartender and
stripper the entrance the security guy
you
ready the counter stage right now Bret
and then he's like holding the mic you
put the dagger what's that noise oh that
is just my laundry who's doing another
room exactly so my wife doesn't hear the
music yeah yeah he did admit to the
moonshine or cuz he creates his own men
he's such an entrepreneur right [ __ ]
cut out the middleman he does everything
he makes his own alcohol he charges at
the door he does the show himself funny
because they interviewed one of his
neighbors which is a guy who a patron
yeah cuz he was like well I mean what's
the big deal I mean as long as no one's
getting hurt you see yeah you like I've
actually been there a couple of times
just it's just like a whole bunch of
guys just drinking there's nothing wrong
with that but it to look it seems based
on how they write it that he's trying to
hide the fact that he's one of the
patron for sure oh yeah
like he's one of the regulars he's not
just the occasional goer he has his own
chair reserved and so they were saying
that the alcohol law enforcement agent
ale agent whatever that was company
alcohol law enforcement it's not just
like the eightieth they call it ale
agents maybe they have their own yeah
they found the moonshine and they also
found some drugs oh yeah and they also
found guns oh and so they're saying like
is dangerous I bet you they found those
things in separate places but it's made
to sound that way they found like a bag
of weed in his bedroom and inside of his
safe there was a [ __ ] gun so they
have to write drugs in the article
though to make us out there acting like
this guys Tony Montana no he's just a
[ __ ] dude that goes oh you know
because we get like strippers at our
house he's a [ __ ] entrepreneur in
Japan with a dream yeah man oh wow oh
they should show us the inside no that's
just in strip clubs they look like that
place looks crazy I mean everywhere yeah
have you have you been in New Orleans
[Laughter]
so that looks like long lasting it's
like but New Orleans strip clubs are
kind of dingy dude like New Orleans is
that that type of joint too like when
you go I forgot what that strip is
called that everybody goes to but I went
there for a brand deal look at Burberry
so it looks dope at night yeah daytime
just like Vegas [ __ ] trash oh I said
it's too like the way they approach you
to go in the strip clubs [ __ ]
aggressive dude he goes sup man you like
[ __ ] or what out there literally just
covering their nipples and like a string
for their like vagina and their ass and
they're standing outside now that we
figured it out though cuz we had Isaac
so as soon as you start pointing a
camera they rush the girls inside from I
just got a goal like this and they all
got an L go away yeah the daytime I just
made I was recently told Nikki that up
my bucket list it on my bucket list is
going to a strip club during the day cuz
I've never done that before and I have
always wanted to go there and just like
be there like noon you want to see the
customers want see the customers do it
tomorrow yeah well no but my bucket list
is things that are not that great you
know I mean like drinking a case of
water beyond your that's gonna help me
die that's gonna help me die so you got
to go to the airport strip clubs
yes that's right well the ones near LAX
yeah yeah I don't even know that go
there because my friend used to what do
you call a bodyguard or a bouncer and
then the lunchtime get lunch actually
eat there yeah they have he's thankful
were strippers and the worst customers
come at that time exactly that's why I
want to see man I just want to see it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]